can we talk about what only fans does to
society because you know we were talking
about this downstairs like a couple days
ago it's basically all of these young
women are deciding that they want to be
prostitutes it's just like it's it's
like a digital version of it but it's
basically the same thing men can
subscribe to pay you money in exchange
for this Behavior there was this uh clip
that's going viral right now I think
clown World reposted it from the
whatever podcast where a woman says that
she was hooking up with a guy just to
break his heart
right yeah and then and then you know
the dude from whatever is like she says
her hobby is the humble men and he's
like and someone says you're a stripper
yeah he says it yeah and then she's like
yeah but I take their money and it's
like no listen I feel like a lot of what
we're talking about what you're
describing with um dudes who have like
addictions porn addictions and you
mentioning like women getting run
through whatever and then only fans and
stripping is that people are doing
things that are genuinely detrimental
across the board throughout the study
not just related to dating yeah and
there are people who don't want to feel
bad about it because misery loves
company so they tell everybody what
you're doing is totally fine keep doing
it even though it's really bad and the
obvious example the the actual visible
example is morbid obesity like we know
that if you are eating and gorging
yourself you will die sooner and we
don't want that we want you to live a
long healthy life but the people who
enjoy eating hot fudge sundaes all day
every day don't want to stop they're
addicted so instead of accepting and
admitting themselves they have a problem
they seek out validation from other
people who are addicted creating a
society of people who are engaging in
extremely detrimental behaviors across
the board which brings you back to only
fans I I've met women who have said
they've tried it and they gave up
because they weren't making money and
now they have a bunch of porn online
it's everywhere they were like people
people stole the videos people recorded
the videos people did a whole bunch of
stuff and they made like 17 and that was
it and that there you are you're you're
a prostitute forever never never you can
never change it yeah I mean the I can't
remember what the average amount of
money is for a woman that goes on only
fans but it's not a lot I thought it was
like 20 bucks or something yeah it's not
I wish I don't remember what it is but I
remember thinking like wow that's such a
low payout but it's also why is there
any amount is enough for someone to do
that in this culture like but I I think
Sheamus women and men are very very
different yeah and it is sad but
consider there's tons of stories of
women quitting their jobs to become
prostitutes or like marrying into money
I mean it's basically similar kind of
thing if you don't love the guy sure
gold digging but it's it's still
different to marry someone like to enter
into a binding contract granted now with
no fault divorce it is kind of
meaningless it used to be like you got
married you were there till the dude
died and then okay Al Pacino's like 90
he's got a 28 9 year old wife or
something and she's pregnant yep man the
wild oh you know in defense of uh only
fans I think it was evilovia was talking
about this because she did it uh youporn
and the porn industry girls
you can't guarantee that they're not 18
uh in the porn industry it's very
difficult to vet the process so there's
a lot of child porn that gets through in
that system whereas on only fans it's
vetted a hundred percent so you know
everything on there is legal and above
board I'm not I'm not opposed to porn
generally like I'm fairly libertarian
people can do their thing my issue is
there is a social Trend among many women
there's like a story of like a nurse
like I was a nurse making 50 000 a year
and I quit now I make 200 doing porn
like
is is this a good thing I I don't think
it is like I don't know maybe maybe I I
should start reading some more books by
sex positive feminists no that is the
last thing that you should do that is
I think women lie too about how much
they make because I went on the whatever
podcast and there was like I don't know
four or five girls that said they made
over 20k a month and I ran the numbers
and it was like less than 2 000 people
or 3 000 people in the U.S make the
number of like make the money they're
saying they make them like what are the
odds they're all on one show I think
there's some incentive to lie about it
oh absolutely well yeah well that's also
a fair point and it's a sad thing
because because a person might be
embarrassed how embarrassing would that
be oh my gosh you put your body on the
internet and you can get 10 buyers
this is this is the reality of it yeah
so so there are a few there are people a
few people I know I know one woman who
did uh cam girl stuff and she literally
thought that she would be making she see
these stories the here's the crazy thing
these stories encourage more women to do
it and it never works so you get these
women to go on these shows and say I'm
making 20K a month and they're not and
then I have a friend who's like I'm
gonna try doing it and I'm like yeah you
probably shouldn't do that it's not
going to work out and then when what did
she say said all it was was people
sending messages saying please post for
free please post for free I want a free
sample and then she made like 17 and was
like this is this is nuts like there's
no money here but now everything's out
there well ins oh go ahead well and the
girl on the show I looked at her only
fans I mean not like that you know I
just wanted to see how many subscribers
she had and there was like no premium
content so I was like how where are you
making she said she made 50k a month so
I'm like it's not true well no I was
thinking it could be like prostitution
oh that was my thought like over it's I
think I think it is prostitutions yes
well yeah but I was thinking like if
they don't make it through there maybe
they go through yeah well it's it's a
very sad thing because you could also
imagine someone being embarrassed about
that not admitting there not making any
money and then what they're saying to
make themselves sound impressive
convinces more young women to do the
same thing that they're doing so you
know maybe they're making fifty dollars
like again no amount makes that worth it
but that is um that is really sad well I
got good news though with AI technology
all of this industry will be wiped out
wiped out clean all these women there
will not be women who are making a
living doing this anymore it's going to
be a bunch of dudes and they're going to
be going to you know
porn.ai or whatever I don't even know
that exists and they're going to be like
render me a video of like two guys in a
check and then it's gonna render the
video and they're gonna upload it and
charge five bucks for it but then what's
gonna happen is every person in the
world will just buy a subscription to
the porn AI bot and just tell it
whatever they want yeah and so then
women will be like these women who are
doing it now are going to be like I
can't make any money doing it anymore
dude porn has already caused so many
problems for society AI porn is just
going to be unbearable dude people are
going to go insane you'll be able to
change it in real time you'll be
watching today
I have a question do you think with the
growing like rise of sexless men that
porn is actually like helpful to society
because they're not then aggressive
maybe that typically happens I think
like wasn't that a conspiracy theory and
also with with do you think it keeps
together sexless marriages
uh so if so I would say that if it's a
crutch to lean on it actually causes far
more problems than it solves uh I think
that like the Warped understanding of
sex that we have in the first place that
allows for for porn to be uh not only
legal but so prolific is the same
corrupt set of sexual morals that allows
for things like no fault divorce and for
these sexless marriages to happen so I
think it's all one uh part of the same
corrupt infrastructure and we just have
to do away with all of it you know you
know I think I think women care
substantially more about what other
women think of them oh yeah and so
that's a big component of all all of
this when it comes to marriages when it
comes to people who are upset there you
you and maybe it's just because of of
what I see in TVs and movie and what I
hear from other people which are who are
influenced by teams and movie but it
seems so often there's many stories of
women who are like in a relationship
with the husband and then they're
talking to their other woman friend and
they say here's the thing my husband and
they go oh no that's so bad and they're
like oh no and now I feel bad about it
you're at absolutely right like I've
talked to so many and that's why like
the Trad cons will come in and be like
oh just find the right girl she won't do
any of like the divorce stuff they won't
be in a sexless marriage just find the
right girl but the thing is like women
are so easily influenced like I'll have
guys for the divorce documentary they'll
have a girl she had like all the typical
like checkbox like boxes checked that
you would want in a wife and then like
she gets in the wrong group of friends
and then she just divorces her husband
takes the kids takes half and just ruins
this man's life well divorce is
contagious right yeah we know that if
you have a friend who's divorced you're
you're more likely to get divorced I
would say that it's really important
look it in our modern time we have this
very like atomized vision of what family
should be you know you just have two
people living in a house together with
their children no extended family nearby
and you're also not part of a community
that has the same values as you I would
say uh if somebody wants to live a
traditional life it's not enough to find
one other traditional person right uh
you you probably want to be surrounded
by people in a community that is more
traditional where it would be an
absolute Scandal if you end up up
getting divorced well I just I think
that's going to be harder and harder
with media absolutely and so but the
thing is I just think things won't
really change until they change the laws
that's my personal opinion I think
there's truth and it's it's so difficult
because 50 50 custody would be so like
where and maybe like something to
protect men from not getting absolutely
wrecked with like child support spouses
well we should just get rid of no-fault
divorce agreed all right banished like
listen I've been birth control too this
is what this is oh my God yes and I just
take away repeal the 19th this is what
what feminists are arguing we did a
segment on no fault divorce and then
they started ragging on us and they gave
Sheamus's quote to Ian Ian it was one of
my best quotes ever they gave it to even
Ian Crossland even cross even cross even
got a good quote what they're arguing is
that marriage is now better because
women and men can both of them can just
leave whenever they want that's what
makes them that's better that's
literally not marriage so my point is
okay fine here's here's what I want to
say to all of those feminists whatever
it is you have now let's keep it exactly
the way it is but we'll create something
called super marriage after you're
married you decide to enter a super
marriage now you can't get divorced
without a valid reason problem solved
yeah I mean look I agree with you that
we need to end no fault divorce I said
this this is one of the things that
Jezebel was so core uh horrified by that
they quoted it and gave the quote to Ian
Crossland but people people talk about
how many marriages fail and if you know
if we had no we removed no fault divorce
so many people would be stuck in these
marriages all right well they don't
consider is that people are less
cautious about who they choose to marry
because divorce is an option and also
because we live in a culture where
people do have sex before they're
married they end up being blinded by the
sex they don't evaluate the person
objectively they end up become becoming
bonded by all the chemical reactions
that happen in their brain when they
have sex with somebody and so you end up
making really bad decisions people say
well if we change the cultural Paradigm
what what about all these people who
made these bad decisions there's going
to be fewer of them there will be fewer
people making those kinds of decisions
I I was going to answer your question um
about porn and if it's because all I
think it is doing is and I'd love to
talk more about no fault divorce too it
burns my mind almost every day
um that I think it is helping young
people get their aggression out and
maybe it's it's it's winding Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter until it explodes
but a lot of times young sexless men
they just get put into the military to
go kill and I I I'm not seeing that now
I mean it's it's drastic in the other
direction you might argue that nobody or
hardly anybody wants to go fight so
maybe it's the completely depleted the
testosterone of the youth maybe we need
enforce the monogamy actually I have
another question so the more the more
women have been in charge of their own
mate selection the more Partners we've
had so is there something about women
that's actually not monogamous well no
because I think what you're touching I
mean those those things are correlated
right so
um that's correlated with the Advent of
reliable methods of artificial
contraceptive uh and even like even when
you haven't started before like the
birth rate started to decline before it
actually like because a lot of people
think it was the 60s but it's actually
been declining since the 1800s and in
1920 like we do see a dip in the birth
rate and like they they attribute that
to women like living in an apartment
outside like by herself or before she
would go straight from like her parents
house to her husband's house oh wow so
so it's interesting like when you think
about it like it did like women like
then began to have more Partners
sexually so it's like it seems like like
throughout history like they've just
been trying to like keep women from like
not to be so you're saying that
women should be allowed to own property
do I actually have never thought about
that question
um
so I like it I don't know I haven't
thought about it but I think what's been
pretty well understood by basically
every culture through all of history is
like men are gonna try to have sex right
men are going to try to persuade women
to have sex with them and so societies
have understood that we need to get
women to be really good at saying no to
this uh or else everyone's just going to
be having sex outside of marriage you're
gonna have a lot of illegitimate
children a lot of infanticide and
abortion which is what ended up
happening uh that's that's actually not
hyperbolic if you look at ancient Rome
the more sexually licentious people came
the more in fantasized there was I mean
it's a reality do you think I wanna oh
at that point do you think it would be
better for you or just for women in
general to have like three kids with
three different phenomenal dudes or
three kids with one guy I would say
three kids with one guy then I well I
guess I guess you have to if you think
about it from like a gene perspective
you probably get better like quality
jeans I'd imagine if you said they're
like hi but like yeah but for a society
no like the one that's like saying let
me let me try different guys three
different guys because one of the kids
will succeed instead of being like let's
just have kids together and raise them
I'm not I'm just I'm playing Devil's
Advocate I'm like
well they're not good guys yeah exactly
that's what I'm saying thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time